Twitter owner Elon Musk says he is for
free speech one of the realities about
being for free speech
is that you have to be for free speech
or for speech that sometimes might cause
uncomfortable consequences this is the
reality for so-called Free Speech
absolutists we are now learning that
Elon Musk limited Tweets in Turkey
during the tight presidential election
in which president erdogan on Sunday
failed to get to the 50 threshold and
now as a result that election will go to
a runoff
there is a a rolling stone article
Vanity Fair sorry Twitter's Elon Musk
defends decision to limit Tweets in
Turkey during tight presidential
election uh oh is this free speech
critics say the social media platform
allowed the Turkish government to
silence criticism this is an article
from a couple days ago by Jack mccordick
on the eve of the most hotly contested
Turkish election in two decades Twitter
uh oh moved to block posts in the
country in what critics argue is a
capitulation to a call for censorship
from Turkish president erdogan uh in
response to legal process and to ensure
Twitter remains available to the people
of Turkey
we have taken action to restrict access
to some content in Turkey today uh-oh a
second tweet said the restricted content
would be visible to the rest of the
world
as we know and as the Vanity Fair
article explains during his 20 years as
president erdogan has methodically
tightened his grip on power undermining
key Democratic institutions
um Adam Schiff former guest on this
program tweeted the day before a
critical election in Turkey Twitter
appears to be acquiescing to the demands
of the country's autocratic ruler
erdogan and is censoring speech on the
platform given Twitter's total lack of
transparency it is hard to avoid the
conclusion that musk's Promises of free
speech have again Fallen away
uh Twitter didn't say which accounts it
restricted but Turkish minute reported
the censored accounts include Kurdish
businessman Muhammad yakut who claimed
erdogan staged a 2016 coup attempt an
investigative journalist Savari guvin
who reports on corruption in the country
quote it's a disgrace to democracy and
freedom of expression that Twitter has
caved to erdogan Saturday Elon Musk
Twitter CEO and self-proclaimed Free
Speech absolutist defended the
Restriction musk said did your brain
fall out of your head responding to
Matthew Iglesias the choice is have
Twitter throttled in its entirety
or limit access to some tweets which one
do you want now of course the true Free
Speech absolutist would say we are not
going to bow to your authoritarian
threats to block all of Twitter we will
not censor particular tweets at your
demand and if you do block Twitter in
some total we will shout from the
rooftops and make it a global story of
authoritarian censorship that's how a
free speech absolutist would handle
those threats but Elon Musk said all
right we'll limit the content that
erdogan wants limited sadly
this is too common among those who claim
that they are for free speech and we've
talked about it before with the Maga
people free speech Free Speech Free
Speech oh forced Twitter to publish my
coveted disinformation otherwise they're
bad and we will try to uh restrict them
or in some some persecute them uh in the
court of public opinion or potentially
even legally well then you're not really
for the free speech of that Corporation
are you now is it Twitter's right
to restrict access to whatever they want
sure
no one's denying that what we're talking
about is the selective application of
so-called Free Speech absolutism from
self-proclaimed Free Speech Heroes like
Elon Musk we'll continue to cover it
Monday Memorial Day we are doing a
one-day membership special that is going
to knock your socks off it's going to be
crazy people probably should just wear
flip-flops at the time to not even have
to deal with the socks being knocked off
get on my mailing list at
davidpackman.com Monday Memorial day
you'll get an email telling you how to
take advantage of this stunning and
appalling membership discount by now all
of us know how creepy it is to talk to a
friend about something and then get ads
that are related when you use a free
email service from a big Tech
Corporation your emails are scanned even
if you're emailing your spouse or your
doctor which is why I recommend and
start mail the email service that never
scans or analyzes your email our sponsor
start mail also lets you create
unlimited email address aliases so you
don't even have to give out your real
email address this protects you from
spam and phishing attacks phishing
attacks are becoming way more
sophisticated with the rise of chat GPT
by the way start mail lets you encrypt
any email you send even if the recipient
isn't using encryption unlike the big
Tech email Services who store even your
deleted emails when you delete an email
in start mail it is gone migrating from
your current email service to start mail
is just a few clicks so what are you
waiting for stop letting big Tech
corporations spy on your email my
audience gets 50 off your first year at
startmail.com Pacman the link is down
below